[Music]
i would like to confess that i used to
clean men's houses wearing lingerie
usually about
20 minutes in i would then take off the
lingerie so that would be
part of the service and it would almost
be like
a journey for them
so
i'd like to confess that i am absolutely
obsessed with rihanna and i dm her every
day
what do you mean what do you dm her
about
well um i sent her a lot of messages you
know just asking her how she is
um i have a lot of conversations as if
we were friends because in my head i
believe like we're sisters we're friends
you know
and has she ever messaged you back uh
no
but
one day i'm keeping the hope alive that
she will what would you like to confess
today i've got a form of ocd that means
that i have intrusive and damaging
thoughts about my partner's previous
past and have spent a lot of the last
couple of years thinking about what she
did before me what kind of things do you
do you end up focusing on thinking about
so obviously we met on a dating app so
it first started with who else
she met on that dating app whether they
met before me whether they liked each
other more than they liked me
uh
i heard about a couple of one-night
stands and the details of those
one-night stands really stuck in my head
i knew that one of them drove a certain
car so enita is a very popular car as
well any time i saw this car that my
heart would leap and i'd have no idea
what was going on it wasn't until i saw
someone else talking in a podcast about
retroactive jealousy ocd that i knew
that something was actually wrong with
me and i wasn't just losing my mind
you're in a relationship at the moment
i'm yeah she's probably the only person
other than you guys now who knows that i
have this condition i've sort of briefly
mentioned it to one or two people but
it's not recognized and people just hear
it as past jealousy i've been called
misogynistic i've been told that i need
to work on my self-esteem i've been told
that i've got low confidence it is a
form of ocd and if you don't get help or
you don't seek to improve your way of
thinking it can be extremely damaging
for like i said for a long time it was
all i could think about and how does it
feel getting that off your chest i can
physically feel my life i feel lighter i
can actually feel like a relief that
i've just said it all out loud even if
it is behind the screen
i would like to confess that i used to
clean men's houses wearing lingerie
usually about
20 minutes in i would then take off the
lingerie so that would be
part of the service and it would almost
be like
a journey for them something to look
forward to
you know so i didn't start out like boom
naked that was the service that they
were they were paying for
purchase what would you like to confess
i would like to confess that in my
younger days i was a bit of a firebug
firebug what does that mean
firebug basically means set fire to
things
that you probably shouldn't do what kind
of things would you set fire to
paper my quill
basically anything i could get my hands
on that i thought would cause a big fire
i set fire to things i shouldn't have
which led to my mum removing
flammable things from the house then i
started setting fire to toilet roll but
because that was a lot that set fire a
lot quicker than paper i panicked and i
freed up my sister and set her coat on
fire
was she all right what happened
um we managed to get the coat off before
she suffered with like any burns
so she's fine but the coat is um
cremated
where did that impulse come from i feel
like it was just the easiest way for me
to let go of my aggression at the time
hi so um
my name's gary mcgraw
so i'd like to confess today that i
regret the first time i ever started
using drugs
and uh it ruined my life pretty much
from then on so when did you start
taking drugs gary
i started taking drugs when i was about
14.
we started off just smoking weed and
then i did work experience in a
restaurant and
i went full time in the restaurant i
left home at 15 and went full time in
the restaurant and i was using a lot of
speed when i was 18 moved to london to
work in a different restaurant and the
cocaine just kind of
came along and overtook everything so uh
yeah it was cocaine really that
started ruining my life more than
anything else
ruined a lot of relationships eventually
i started becoming unreliable at work
because i wasn't sleeping i was going to
work
on drugs
me and my fiance split up
and i
i thought the best thing i could do was
to get out of london because i was
killing myself with coke
and i moved to tenerife for
six months
um
i met a girl from ireland and i moved to
ireland to be of her for two years
that was just pure alcohol and uh
drinking before work in the morning and
drinking during the day at work
and
that that fell apart after two years i
was estranged from my son for many years
so
i decided to come back to london
and um
i became homeless so you're clean now
how are things going today i feel okay i
feel good
i have my son now
most of the time at he's 17 and i've
been very open with him he knows
everything so i've got a little
one-bedroom flat in bromley
so everything's going everything's going
well yeah if it's going well
so i would like to confess a time when
my friend called me
and i didn't answer the call and he
ended up committing suicide initially
when it just hap when it happened
i actually thought it was my fault like
maybe if i would have answered the phone
call i could have
you know
convinced him not to go through i didn't
know he was at such a low point
but now it's just i just keep on
thinking back to it and just hoping that
his family's okay
what does it feel like talking about
that in one way it makes me it reminds
me of it like i kind of i'm kind of
watching it in my head
but there's some sort of relief because
i'm expressing myself so since i'm
expressing myself and i'm letting it out
for example it's like smoking you're
letting the smoke out so as you're
talking about it you're kind of you're
not keeping it bottled up inside you're
letting it out so it won't be on your
mind a lot so you won't dwell on it it's
a bit of a weird one but when i was
younger i used to drown snails do you
feel bad about it now um i feel bad
about it now because anyone shouldn't
have been doing that as a child or as
well an adult shouldn't do that either
but i feel bad for the snails um and
also bad for myself because i didn't
have many friends so i think it was like
a thing that i was like oh i don't have
friends so let's do this instead i'm a
vegetarian now so i think i may be
giving back to society a little bit
maybe i would like to confess that i
took someone's virginity when i
shouldn't have so what do you mean what
happened um when i was abroad traveling
i was in a country
and where i met this guy where
according to his religion and culture it
was strictly against having sex before
marriage
but
we managed to sneak into his family home
together and have sex anyway and i took
his virginity the morning after how did
he feel
um he felt like he had a really great
time but he also felt really bad like
he'd committed a sin against his
religion do you regret it looking back i
don't regret it because i had a great
time but i wish i hadn't caused someone
else pain
i never looked at my father like
straight in the face looking like this
like with whole full look
how does that make you feel
i feel like
maybe he thinks i was a mistake
because you're supposed to love your
kids